صباح العربيه مستمر معكم اعزائنا
المشاهدين وهذا البرنامج بالارقام احصاءات
طوال سنوات عرضه نحو 18 عاما مرت على عرض
الحلقه الاولى من برنامج صباح العربيه
والذي بدا في تاريخ التاسع من يوليو لعام
2005 اكثر من 4000 حلقه قدمها مذيع صباح
العربيه على الهواء مباشره والتي احتوت
على عشرات الالاف من المواضيع المتنوعه ما
يزيد عن 24 الف ضيف حلوا على برنامج صباح
العربيه بين النجوم وفنانين عرب واجانب
اطباء ومهندسين اخصائيه تجميل والكثير من
الناس العاديين بقصص غير عاديه وما يزيد
عن 250 مقطع من صباح العربيه حقق اكثر من
مليون مشاهده على مواقع التواصل الخاصه
بشبكه العربيه وبرنامج صباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
وخلال عشرين عاما الماضيه مرت صناعه
الاعلام بتغييرات من كان يتوقع عام 2003
ان الناس ستتابع التلفزيون على هواتفهم
ومن كان يتوقع ان يحول التواصل الاجتماعي
اشخاصا مجهولين في البلدان النائيه الى
نجوم عالمدينه احب الملايين فكره الاصوات
البديله وصناع المحتوى على وسائل التواصل
اصبح هناك برامج يتابعها الملايين ووجودها
رقمي فقط حلقاتها تعرض على الانترنت بشكل
حصري في ظل هذه المنافسه تاقلمت وسائل
الاعلام التاريخيه واصبحت قناه العربيه
مثلا ثاني اكبر القنوات على شبكات التواصل
عالميا من حيث عدد المشاهدات